hallo und willkommen zu heute live es
herrscht ein ziemliches Chaos am
Frankfurter Flughafen und dazu gab es am
Vormittag folgenden Tweet den wir uns
gerne gemeinsam angucken können von der
Lufthansa da steht aktuell sind die
Fluggesellschaften der Lufthansa Group
von einem it-ausfall betroffen die ist
für zu Flugverspätungen und Ausfällen
wir bedauern die Unannehmlichkeiten die
unseren Fluggästen dadurch entstehen
welche Unannehmlichkeiten das sind da
sind nämlich nicht wenige das werden wir
uns gleich noch mal genau angucken
zuvor ist vielleicht auch noch mal hier
der Übeltäter denn das ist sozusagen
auch schon die Erkenntnis der Stunde
diese it-panne ist nämlich nach
Einschätzung des Unternehmens und die
Telekom hat ist inzwischen bestätigt
ausgelöst worden von Bauarbeiten ja da
sehen wir den Übeltäter also dieser
Bagger hat offenbar ein Glasfaserkabel
Bauarbeiten der Telekom wohlgemerkt
durchtrennt und dabei ist es dann
offenbar zu einem ja Unglück gekommen
sie sehen hier auch vielleicht noch mal
den Kabelsalat der dann dadurch
entstanden ist also das sieht alles
nicht besonders gut aus und das führt
eben jetzt zu folgenden Bildern die wir
auch vorbereitet haben die Auswirkungen
wie gesagt sind gravierend wir gucken
uns das gerade noch mal an also da geht
im Moment nicht viel zumindest nicht was
eingehende Flüge angeht und auch nicht
was äh den Flugverkehr innerhalb
Deutschlands angeht also lange schlagen
wie wir das auch aus anderen
Zusammenhängen kennen von Streiks etc
auch darauf wenn wir später noch mal
eingehen das kommt auf die Fluggäste zu
am Ende der Woche wohl aber das ist
jetzt erstmal das aktuelle Problem und
darüber sprechen wir mit Stefan
Schlösser da steht das schon am
Frankfurter Flughafen Stefan also
Baggerarbeiten
dadurch ein beschädigtes
Glasfaserkabel und die Auswirkungen sind
gravierend wie stellen Sie sich jetzt im
Moment vor Ort da
tja das ist eine ganz andere Situation
als wenn man sie hat wenn zum Beispiel
ein Streik angekündigt ist dann können
sich alle darauf vorbereiten dann wissen
alle da passiert ist was da wird
wahrscheinlich wenig gehen man ist
darauf vorbereitet aber diese Sache die
kann man wie aus heiterem Himmel davon
wollen alle kalter erwischt natürlich
auch die Passagiere die sind hier heute
morgen hergekommen und dachten prima ab
geht's in den Urlaub oder eine
Geschäftsreise oder Freunde Bekannte
versuchen und es wäre auf einmal wird
nichts draus weil die Luft die Flüge der
Lufthansa wirklich alle gestrichen sind
da geht einfach nichts mehr weil ihm
diese
it-problematik besteht die Flugzeuge
können nicht abgefertigt werden das
Boarding kann nicht passieren der
Check-In kann nicht passieren dann
können die Flugzeuge dementsprechend
natürlich auch nicht starten wenn ich
mir so wenn ich mich hier so umschaue im
Flughafen dann sehe ich wirklich immer
wieder sehr sehr lange Schlangen ich
sehe sehr sehr viele Menschen die ihre
Handys in der Hand haben und auf dem
Handy suchen nach Alternativen
reisewegen Suche nach Informationen was
ist überhaupt passiert gucken auf der
Lufthansa Seite und gucken eben wie
komme ich vielleicht Weg denn es gibt ja
noch ein paar Möglichkeiten wer in der
Deutschen Reich der sollte am besten auf
die Deutsche Bahn ausweichen die Züge
fahren ja immerhin noch und wenn
internation am Flughafen naja der muss
halt gucken dass er vielleicht auf eine
andere Airline umbuchen kann die jetzt
noch fliegt um versuchen da einen Platz
zu kriegen ansonsten ja der ein oder
andere
Reisewunsch heute der wird schon
geplatzt sein Stefan du hast dich vor
Ort auch schon mal umgehört wir haben
einige
sammeln können von Betroffenen zu
Passagieren dass wir uns vielleicht
gerade auch noch mal anhören da herrscht
relativ große Ratlosigkeit
als Fluggast bekommt man unter die
Informationen das Pflege gecancelt sind
und man wartet angeht ein anderthalb
Stunde und danach kommt die Nachricht
Fluge cancelt mit dem Hinweis sich an
diesem Schalter hier anzustellen
Umgebung buchen zu können ob das geht
wenn das Computersystem nicht läuft dann
bleibt fraglich
jetzt gerade nichts tun kann schauen wir
mal wie es weitergeht wäre im 21
Jahrhundert dass man sowas noch erlebt
ist halt nicht so toll
ja nicht so toll das kann man sich
vorstellen wer ist denn Stefan jetzt
noch mal ganz genau von dieser Panne
betroffen ist das die Lufthansa sind das
auch also die Tochtergesellschaften sind
das alle Airlines wie wie kann man das
Zusammenfassen
ja nach Angaben der Lufthansa ist die
Lufthansa Group als Ganzes betroffen das
heißt nicht nur die Lufthansa selbst
sondern auch alle Tochtergesellschaften
die ihm zum Konzern gehören andere
Fluggesellschaften allerdings wiederum
nicht sondern ihm tatsächlich nur die
Lufthansa Gruppe aber die Lufthansa
Gruppe ist natürlich in Deutschland die
maßgebliche Airline hier am Frankfurter
Flughafen allemal ein absoluter Großteil
der am Tag stattfindende Wert von
Lufthansa eben abgewickelt und
dementsprechend groß sind auch eben die
Auswirkungen man kann jetzt noch gar
nicht sagen das weißt die Lufthansa
selbst noch nicht wie viele Flüge am
Ende betroffen sein werden wie viele
Flüge heute nicht stattfinden werden und
wie viele Reisende am Ende auch von
diesem Chaos betroffen sein werden das
ist jetzt noch gar nicht ganz klar man
hofft halt dass dieses Kabel dieses
ominöse Glasfaserkabel in Frankfurt auf
der Baustelle möglichst schnell
repariert werden möglichst heute bis zum
frühen Abend Hoffmann dass es dann
klappt und wieder fertig ist so dass die
Systeme wieder hochlaufen können das
wird dann sicherlich auch noch ein
Augenblick dauern das wird auch noch ein
bisschen ruckeln bis sich der Flugplan
wieder normalisiert hat aber man hofft
zumindest das ab heute Abend die
Situation man sich entspannen wird
langsam ja drücken wir dafür schon mal
die Daumen es war die Rede davon dass
zwischenzeitlich zumindest die Landungen
für alle Fluggesellschaften ausgesetzt
worden sind jetzt habe ich vorhin
gelesen also einzelne Landungen finden
wohl wieder statt was hat es damit auf
sich da ging es wohl auch darum dass man
befürchtet hat es könnte sich zu sehr
drängen am Flughafen
genau das stimmt das ist der richtige
Grund Frankfurt hat ja immer schon einen
Platzproblem Frankfurt ist kein großer
Flughafen zwar als die Passagiere was
das Aufkommen betrifft schon aber von
der Fläche her nicht das kann man nicht
vergleichen mit den Flughäfen die man im
arabischen Raum z.B hat wo man wirklich
auf die grüne Wiese riesige Flughäfen
setzen konnte und dementsprechend Platz
hat in Frankfurt gibt es immer schon
Platzmangel und jeder Stellplatz ist
wichtig jeder Stellplatz ist begehrt und
wenn die Flugzeuge nicht abfliegen
können naja da sind die Stellplätze
natürlich irgendwann voll und blockiert
wo sollen dann die neu landen den
Flugzeuge denn hin wenn alles blockiert
ist das war der Grund warum er gesagt
hat von der Deutschen Flugsicherung wir
sperren jetzt in Frankfurter Flughafen
wir alle ankommenden Flugzeuge die
müssen wir umleiten die müssen
Ausweichen nach Nürnberg nach Düsseldorf
sonst wohin wo eben noch Kapazitäten
frei sind um den Frankfurter Flughafen
ganz einfach zu entlassen weil es hier
schlecht unter greifen keine
Parkposition dann mehr gibt und der
Flughafen dann einfach vollgelaufen ist
und das kann natürlich auch nicht in der
Sache sein die Flüge noch raus derzeit
ja soweit war das von hier aus sehen
können wir können nicht direkt aufs aus
Rollfeld schauen von hier aus aber auch
wenn ich auf die Anzeigetafel schaue ja
bei Lufthansa steht fast immer gecancelt
oder Ausweichen auf dem Zug aber die
anderen Fluggesellschaften laut
Anzeigetafel fliegen die noch so gesehen
ja es geht immer noch Flüge raus aber
eben keine Lufthansa Flüge ja Stefan
danke dir für den Moment vielleicht
gerade auch noch mal der Hinweis die
Lufthansa bittet die Betroffenen
Fluggäste sich vor Anreise zum Flughafen
über den Status ihres Fluges auf der App
oder Webseite dann zu informieren
fluggäste mit innerdeutschen Flügen
können bis Sonntag auf die Deutsche Bahn
ausweichen das ist das was du gerade
auch schon gesagt hast Stefan danke
schön für diese ja Eindrücke vor Ort für
einen Moment danke schön Stefan
Schlösser und wir sprechen über dieses
Problem mit einem Luftfahrt Experten
sehr geschätzt und zugeschaltet jetzt
aus Hamburg es ist Heinrich groß Bongard
der ist ja herzlichen
Dank dass Sie dafür zur Verfügung stehen
Herr Bongard großbongard und einen
schönen Tag nach Hamburg fangen wir mal
an mit den Ursachen also die
bahnbauarbeiten wir haben es vorhin
schon gesehen vielleicht zeigen wir
gerade noch mal dieses Bild das ist
wirklich irgendwie ja etwas ist skurril
also das ist dieses
glasfaserkabelnetz was ich vorhin schon
angesprochen habe also das ist schon so
dass man sich ja fragt wie kann das
eigentlich sein dass die Bahn
offensichtlich da ein Kabel durchtrennt
und dann einen Tag später wohlgemerkt
der Flugbetrieb quasi lahmgelegt wird
wie wie erklären Sie sich das
das kann ich mir auch nicht erklären ich
bin keine IT-Experte
aber es kann natürlich durchaus sein
dass einzelne Systeme erst noch liefen
und erst wirklich heute morgen als dann
die volle der volle Betrieb losging dann
sich die Auswirkungen ihrer Gänze
gezeigt haben aber gibt es da
normalerweise kein Backup für der
live-fälle also das selbst wenn so ein
Kabel mal beschädigt wird also auch wenn
sie keine IT-Experte sind aber was
hinter ihre Kenntnisse gibt's da keine
Rückfall Option keine Notfallsysteme
es gibt schon
Notfallsystem es gibt schon Backups und
es ist ja nicht die komplette IT
ausgefallen es gibt ja offenbar Systeme
die funktionieren aber es ist eben
wohl das ausgefallen was mit der
Abfertigung der Passagiere zu tun hat
und das natürlich ganz es ist sehr das
kann man in der Tat so sagen die
Auswirkungen sind relativ massiv also es
ist ja eben wir hatten gerade auch von
dem Kollegen Schlösser ja schon gehört
geht also jedenfalls nicht mehr viel was
die innerdeutschen Flüge angeht was ist
jetzt das Gebot der Stunde was muss
jetzt die Lufthansa machen was müssen
die Passagiere jetzt machen
die Passagiere den kann man nur raten
Ruhe zu beraten ich weiß das ist ganz
schwierig in dieser Situation weil wenn
man drin steckt in dem Chaos das jetzt
am Frankfurter Flughafen herrscht und
keine Informationen bekommt weil auch
natürlich die Mitarbeiter an den
Schaltern keine Informationen haben ist
das Situation die sehr schwer
auszuhalten ist und wenn man jetzt los
fliegen will ein Flug vor hat noch heute
Abend
kann man sagen klar Lufthansa App gucken
aber sich drauf einstellen dass da nicht
stattfindet denn ist dieses Chaos im
Flugbetrieb wieder einsortiert ist dass
alle Flüge so stattfinden wie sie sollen
dass wir ohne Frage noch zwei drei Tage
dauern alle Landungen waren
zwischenzeitlich ausgesetzt wir hatten
es für eine angesprochen einzelne
Landung gibt es jetzt wohl wieder aber
eigentlich war ja nur die Lufthansa
betroffen warum betrifft das dann alle
na ja so ein Flughafen hat halt nur eine
Menge eine bestimmte Menge an Platz sie
haben ja das die Zahl der Flugzeuge
reingehen und die Zahl der Flugzeuge die
rausgehen und wenn das man kennt das aus
wintersituationen das Winterchaos wenn
das nicht funktioniert wenn die die raus
sollen nicht mehr raus können wegen
schlechten Wetters dann bricht er sofort
alles zusammen dann haben sie eine
Überlastung das die Parkflächen voll
sind dann haben sie aber Überlastung im
Terminal das auf einmal Passagierströme
zu groß werden das auf einmal eine Menge
Menschen im Terminal ist für die die
ganzen Gebäude gar nicht gebaut sind und
deshalb versucht man das zu verhindern
indem man sagt wir machen hier erstmal
dicht und Leiden vorsorglich um ist denn
zu befürchten dass andere Drehkreuze
davon auch betroffen sein könnten
München etwas
nein da gibt es derzeit keine
Hinweise darauf das ist offenbar eine
Geschichte die es rein auf Frankfurt
beschränkt wir hatten für eine auch von
Stefan Schlösser gehört dass die Telekom
hofft den Schaden zumindest bis heute
Abend wieder behoben zu haben ist denn
damit dann das Problem schon gelöst also
was schätzen Sie wie lange dauert es bis
ich dann der Flugverkehr wieder
normalisiert hat
nun man kennt das von Winterchaos also
wenn irgendwo wegen Schnee oder wegen
Sturm der Flugverkehr zusammenbricht
wenn da Flüge gestrichen werden müssen
ähm Abflüge nicht stattfinden können
Flugzeuge umgeleitet werden müssen dann
dauert es in aller Regel zwei Tage
manchmal sogar drei Tage bis wieder
alles eingetaktet ist das heißt bis die
Flugzeuge wieder da sind wo sie
eigentlich nach ihren Umläufen sein
müssen wo die besagt dass die Besatzung
wieder an ihrem äh da sind wo dann ihr
Flugzeug ist also ein hochkomplexes
System und wenn das einmal durcheinander
gerät dann kriegt man das nicht
innerhalb von ein paar Stunden wieder
alles geregelt vielleicht mal die
allgemeine Frage ist man da im Moment
schon zu abhängig überhaupt jetzt von IT
system wir gucken vielleicht gerade mal
in dem Zusammenhang in die USA am 11
Januar gab es da auch eine Computerpanne
hat den us-flugverkehr damals massiv
durcheinander gebracht tausende Flüge
sind verspätet oder gestrichen worden
also wie stark ist man da abhängig von
diesem System inzwischen
es gibt glaube ich
kaum eine andere Branche vielleicht die
Banken die ähnlich stark von
IT abhängig sind und bei denen Ausfälle
so unmittelbar auch dann nach außen
wahrnehmbar werden
ist man zu stark abhängig nein es gibt
eigentlich keine Wahl man kann ein
solches komplexes System eine Flotte mit
mehreren 100 Flugzeugen die kann man
überhaupt nicht anders steuern
das kann man gar nicht anders betreiben
als mit moderner IT in den USA der Fall
mit der FLA ähm die Sperrung des
Luftraums die hatte
natürlich andere Gründe da konnten
bestimmte Nachrichten
sogenanntens nicht mehr weitergeleitet
werden die informieren die Besatzungen
darüber ob beispielsweise irgendwo eine
Flughafen eine Bahn gesperrt ist ob es
Hindernisse gibt ob Funkfeuer gesperrt
sind um Lufträume gesperrt sind
die sind essentiell und deshalb hat man
nach dem Ausfall dieses Systems dann für
mehrere Stunden den Luftraum gesperrt
aber das war dann relativ schnell wieder
im Golf also dazu gibt es keine große
Alternative aber es scheint trotzdem
keine besonders gute Woche für Fluggäste
zu sein denn am Freitag will werde die
Warnstreiks auf große deutsche Flughäfen
ausweiten davon wäre auch Frankfurt
unter anderem betroffen aber auch
München Stuttgart Dortmund Hannover
Bremen also das klingt nicht besonders
gut keine gute Woche oder für die
Passagiere
das ist keine gute Woche für die
Passagiere man muss auch sagen das ist
keine gute Woche für die Lufthansa denn
dieses kostet einen Haufen Geld so eine
Störung in dieser Größenordnung die
kostet bis alles wieder in der Reihe ist
ganz locker mal 10-15 oder auch 20
Millionen das hinterlässt schon tiefe
Spuren das hinterlässt tiefe Spuren ich
gucke gerade noch mal bei unserer
Community ob es da Kommentare bzw Fragen
gibt high Race schreibt uns das ist kein
IT-Problem sondern schlechtes Management
ohne Backup ist einfach ein weiteres
Beispiel für die it-wüste die in
Deutschland vorher Hersteller das ist
doch immer das gleiche oder wie sehen
Sie das
das ist nicht immer das gleiche
es gibt glaube ich es ist man Systeme
für die gibt es ich bin keine IT-Experte
aber für die kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass das da ein vollständiges
Backup kriegt das dann gibt das man da
wirklich alles doppelt vorhalten kann
bei allen Redundanzen die in so ein
System eingebaut sind aber ich glaube
wirklich komplette
komplette Dopplung der Systeme ist gar
nicht zu leisten
ja ich bin gerade noch mal auf der Suche
nach weiteren Fragen die uns erreichen
bzw auch Kommentare Jürgen wöhrheide
schreibt uns über Youtube ich verstehe
nicht warum dich eine Leitung ein ganzer
flughafenlage lahmgelegt werden kann
normal sollten wichtige Verbindungen
redundant ausgelegt sein das heißt
mindestens eine zweite oder mindestens
zwei eher eine oder zwei extra Leitungen
schreibt er so jetzt ist mir gerade hier
dieser Text wieder abhanden gekommen
ansonsten schreibt uns noch Krista
Zeller über Facebook sind eben in
Frankfurt gelandet und haben nichts
mitbekommen interessant war
wahrscheinlich nicht bei der Lufthansa
oder irgendwie blieben sie davon
verschont also wir haben ja vorhin schon
gesagt einzelne Landung haben ja dann
wohl auch wieder stattgefunden ja wir
bewerten das weiter bzw beobachten die
Situation her groß vielleicht gerade
noch mal zum Schluss der Tipp von ihnen
an die Menschen die jetzt vielleicht
betroffen sind wie sollten die sich
verhalten also diejenigen die am
Flughafen sind oder die jetzt vielleicht
demnächst aufbrechen wollten um zu
fliegen was sollten die tun
also wer am Flughafen ist ist es
wirklich nicht einfach aber Ruhe
bewahren
anders kommt man durch diese Situation
nicht durch und
die die abreisen wollen wirklich gut
informieren ob es den wirklich Sinn
macht überhaupt von zu Hause
Lust zu fahren es macht keinen Sinn da
am Flughafen
zu stehen und zu warten ob der Flieger
wirklich losgeht ja das können wir also
auch nur noch mal unterstreichen wie
gesagt das auch der Tipp der Lufthansa
die App oder die Webseite benutzen um zu
gucken was ist da aktuell los bei den
Flügen danke schön Herr groß Bongard für
ihre Einschätzungen Danke schön an
unsere Community für die Fragen auch
wenn es heute nicht allzu viele waren da
trotzdem und wir drücken natürlich
denjenigen die da jetzt gerade
gestrandet sind am Frankfurter Flughafen
die Daumen dass es möglichst bald
weitergehen möge das war unser Stream zu
diesem Thema bis zum nächsten Mal euch
einen schönen Tag ciao